hello everyone and welcome to the new
era on agamotto chess channel where as
of today all of my videos will be in 60
frames per second now I know what you're
thinking it's it's a chess channel you
know most of the thing you see is the
chessboard it doesn't really matter if
it's 30 or 60 frames per second now I do
agree but then again if I will be moving
or maybe moving my hands or explaining
something then you will experience that
in 60 frames per second or if I will be
you know moving a piece in a in a weird
way then you will also enjoy that in in
60 frames per second so that being said
we are here with a very nice game Xhosa
rule kappa blanka vs. bonito he Guinea
Aviles Argentinian chess master we are
still at the 1914 simultaneous
exhibition that was held in Buenos Aires
Argentina we already seen two games and
here in 1922 so some eight years from
this moment
vilius will win the national
championship held in Argentina so he is
a very strong player and we do have some
more information available about him it
is in the first link available in the
description below but it is again in
Spanish so if anyone can give us a hand
I know I can use Google Translate and
just but sometimes Google Translate just
translates it poorly so I thought it'd
be better if some of my native Spanish
speaking viewers would translate it like
maybe in a few words and then just put
it in the comment section where I will
give it a heart or pin it so everyone
can enjoy it that being said let's check
out the game I'm sure you're gonna enjoy
it it's really a simple game but a
well-played game so Capablanca has the
white pieces he opens with d4 we have d5
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 and now
capablanca goes for e3 this is the Col
system we have c6 by black Bishop to d3
and now Bishop to g4 pinning the night
we have c4 e6 by black now black has
this very nice pawn structure and the
light square bishop is out of the pawn
chain so everything is well for Black
Knight B to d2 and now Knight B to d7
also by video cos we have castles by
kappa blanka Bishop to e7 just
developing
Queen to c2 pressuring the h7 pawn and
Bishop to h5 black now wants to go Bush
up to g6 and trade off the light square
bishop as this Queen Bishop battery is
well very strong I will be three by
Capablanca preparing to develop the
light square bishop the dark square
bishop via the b2 square Bishop to g6
and now could Blanca just continues
developing he doesn't mind the exchange
nor can he avoid it
we have Bishop captures Queen captures
and now video guys just castles so for
the moment everything is perfectly fine
video has managed the trade of the light
square bishop which was his weak Bishop
as you can see all of his bones are on
light squares he still has a a dark
square Bishop here so everything is in
order for black rook 81 cover Blanca
develops the rook and now Queen to c7
developing maybe if I will be an idea in
the future but also the rooks are now
connected and black can also start
developing rooks and Capablanca weights
no longer all of his pieces are in
perfect squares we have E 4 and now
black doesn't have to react to the e4
push but then again he 5 is coming so
you will have to react to it we have D
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4
Knight captures and now you could
capture with the Queen but Capablanca
has a different idea and this idea is
mostly the reason why I'm showing this
game as it's just a beautiful idea
we have rook captures on e4 by
capablanca Bishop to f6 now countering
the D effects of the bishop on b2 queen
- III by Capablanca and the now comes c5
and of course you cannot capture as
there's this tension between the two
bishops
so here a couple long has to figure out
how to go about it
kappa blanka goes Knights to e5 and here
black just captures see characters on d4
and now a couple Blancas queen is under
attack but also there's a triple attack
against his knight on e5 so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out how kappa blanka continued this game
as it is just a beautiful maneuver I'll
give you a couple of seconds as usual
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
and well just an excellent excellent
player and for those who who just want
to enjoy the show
here kappa blanka played night captures
on d7 it's a wonderful idea a wonderful
Queen sacrifice and he didn't just play
Knight captures on d7 he played Knight
captures on b7 at 60 frames per second
that's that's really an excellent move
so what's the idea if you capture the
Queen obviously Sakura Blanca had
something in mind you had to figure this
out if you decided to capture on d7
Capablanca idea was Knight captures on
f6 with check if the knight is captured
Luke g4 check King moves and now Bishop
captures on f6 just an amazing checkmate
and if you don't do it for example if
you don't capture the knight which leads
to the immediate checkmate you could go
King to h8 then Kappa Blancas idea was
looked to h4 again threatening rook
captures on h7 with checkmate and after
we block it with h6 Capablanca x' idea
was rook captures on h6 with check only
move his pawn captures and not Knights
the e8 opens up I discovered check from
the bishop to the king and now white
picks up the the Queen King g8 and
Knight captures on c7 and here White has
a knight and the bishop for a rook with
a with a nicely winning position well
cover Blanca would win win it eventually
so after Knight captures on d7 Venegas
decides not to capture the Queen but
rather plays a queen capture Sun d7 and
okay now Capablanca can just trade down
with Bishop captures Bishop captures and
rook captures so although the material
on the board is equal Capablanca the
advantage here is that he has three
points on the Queen side against two
points on the Queen side so this is
something well something to look forward
to as the King will not be able to help
out against the pushing of the pawns
Queen to c7 and now rook F the d1 kappa
blanka now controls the d file with rook
F to be eight black now wants the at
least challenge Capablanca the control
of the d4 of the D file a little bit and
now just before s capablanca has the
advantage on the Queen side he now wants
to push he wants to play c5 and well
perhaps
if if black chan challenges would be six
create a passport we recapture some d4
and now queen capture Sundy for
controlling the eight square now rook to
d8 sorry about that now rook to d8 will
not be a possibility will be six by
black and now g3 first we have looked
the c8 now attacking capablanca spawn
and c4 and now rook to see 100 okay for
the moment cover Blanca had to leave his
control of the D file but it doesn't
matter we looked to d8 attacking the
Queen and Quinta III still couple
Wonka's plan is to push c5 and create a
passed pawn we have king to f8 black
starts improving the position of the
king and now c5 b captures on c5 is
played in town capablanca doesn't
immediately sort of that recaptures on
c5 but first Queen to e4 and now well
you could say that Queen captures on h7
is a threat but if black decided to to
pull the pawn or something you can't
capture because you lose the Queen the
rook would capture the Queen but here
you could pull the pawn well let's say
and c4 but that doesn't really do
anything for you so here black just
tried if you play something like g6 then
capablanca just recaptures and he claims
that he has a passed pawn and a better
position here black played rook to d5
and now comes B captures on c5 Queen
captures on h7 isn't all that impressive
as vibe just goes rook to Queen to d7 in
it it will be very hard for for white to
look for any advantage if you capture
rook d1 check captures captures and now
you will have a very hard time getting
out of all the checks let's say King g2
now you can go Queen d5 check if the
King goes back to just continue checking
him on the on the first rank and if f3
then again you can cap renee to create a
passed pawn of your own on a 7 and after
the King moves you can go Queen back to
the 5 prevent the d5 pawn at the c5 pawn
from marching forward and also you can
now start pushing your own passport upon
forward
so after rook to d5 couple uncle just
plays pawn captures on c5 sorry pawn
captures on c5 and now we have
g6 notice that you still cannot capture
and see
if you play rook captures on c5 then you
get this problem you get Queen to b4
pinning the rook because the King is now
on f8 on a dark square and here you
would just lose a whole rook so here it
is impossible to capture it here black
plate g6 guarding and also making some
room for a king you cannot capture on h7
anymore and here we have a very nice
move back of Blanca just c6 now you have
a passed pawn just push her passed pawn
king to g7 is played and the now comes a
four by Capablanca and here his opponent
played rook to d6 I looked at these six
seems like a very nice idea because well
the Queen and rook have to constantly
keep an eye on the c6 pawn otherwise
you're going to lose it
but well that's often the case in chess
you know things aren't always as they
seem so once again feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
winning move for Capablanca I'll give
you a couple of seconds you know to give
you a chance to decide what we want to
do it or not so feel free to pause the
video for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent butcher of passed pawns and
winner of games and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy so here a cup of lanka
played Queen to e5 check his opponent
played f6 seems like everything is fine
but now comes the move you had to see
Queen captures rook on d6 that's well
that's all there was
his opponent captured Queen Capablanca
pushed c7 and it was in this position
that his opponent Benito he vide agus
resigned to the game unmoved 34 as there
is nothing to do next move couple maka
will just push the pawn to c8 and he
will grab yet another Queen he will be
upper rook and have a completely winning
endgame
yeah I wonderful a wonderful game
bye-bye Capablanca just you know there's
a especially that attempt at a queen
sacrifice and then even though he wasn't
able to sacrifice the Queen then he
managed to do a temporary Queen
sacrifice now you know just just to
amuse the the viewers yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed that this
will be the last game will be showing
from this simultaneous exhibition so
here
we're gonna check up on what Capablanca
did maybe I will show some more games
prior to the 1918 great tournament of
New York work up a bunker will face some
very strong opponents one of them famous
Serbian Grandmaster a borislav hostage
or Borak hostage as you know people know
him so it will be a very enjoyable
tournament I'm sure gonna enjoy it but
before that we might check up on a few
more games we'll see how it goes
yeah once again that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I do hope you're
enjoying you know 60 frames per second
and everything you know do comment on
that if it's at least a bit more
enjoyable I doubt it's like twice as
enjoyable but it might be a little bit
more enjoyable and yeah I would like to
thank Remy your is Mario Encinos
Alexandra Orca wolf on Weller and Paul
staples for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video so your thing called for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content thank you
and I'll see you soon